so Hank you just got set up low to buy
several nerdfighters including Esther or
as she's known on the Internet crazy
crayon thank you know after she helps
run the constantly updating spew of
awesome known as Fe on nerdfighters link
in the doobly-doo she also has cancer
which sucks this weekend a bunch of her
friends got to go up to Boston to visit
her and I went and visited with them for
a day and it was an amazing day of
amazing and it made me really proud to
be a nerdfighter to see these
relationships that began online and
nerdfighteria be so sustaining and
meaningful IRL so what we do oh we all
wrote silly questions on this volleyball
and then we would throw each other the
volleyball and answer the questions like
I had to answer what cover my underwear
was the question is what color is your
underwear panties hi guys in case you
don't know what underwear is it's black
with little white palm trees then we had
to decide which Harry Potter character
Esther would be she's a big Harry Potter
fan more on that in a second Luna half
moon a half Dumbledore we tried to have
a puff fight but it turned into a
head-butting contest as puff fights so
often do yeah
then we went on this insane adventure
through the Twilight streets of Boston
trying to find this one place that had
espresso and gelato then we all had
espresso and felt terribly sophisticated
anyway all night long I was thinking
about how grateful I am to know Esther
and trying to figure out a way like give
thanks for our weird internet-based
cross-generational friendship and then I
remembered the first amazing night of
amazing I spent with Esther was at
LeakyCon a Harry Potter conference and
after all if it weren't for Harry Potter
I would have know Esther and also there
probably wouldn't be a nerdfighteria
then I thought about the fact that
Esther is a huge supporter of the Harry
Potter Alliance a charitable
organization that nerdfighteria often
partners with like remember when
nerdfighteria and the Harry Potter
Alliance raised on in $23,000 to help
Haiti heal and we had the s
dftba load up and go over to Haiti write
that Harry Potter Alliance Hank the HPA
is currently in this huge contest to
potentially win $250,000 to dramatically
improve the amount of worldsuck they can
decrease the HPA is currently in third
place but what if we all go link in the
dooblydoo and we vote and we tell our
friends to vote and they win the
$250,000 which allows them to continue
their work getting books to kids around
the world from the Mississippi Delta to
Rwanda and allows them to grow the work
they do advocating for human rights
around the world and also it is a small
little way of saying tester hi thank you
for being awesome I'm not going to say
that we should win this contest for
Esther because if I say that she will
throw up in the back of her mouth and
hate me I think we should win this
contest with Esther so if you want to
give thanks for the existence of
nerdfighteria and the existence of
Esther and the existence of wonderful
boy wizards please go to the link in the
dooblydoo and vote for the Harry Potter
Alliance so please go vote and thanks
again to everyone in Boston it was so
fun to hang out with you guys Hank
you'll find this out at VidCon but it is
so pleasant to spend time with people
who are wearing your face on their chest
I'll see you on Wednesday or as the
color on the Internet
crazy crayon now that kind of like I'm
robbing a bank right now how would you
describe the assailant sir mmm about six
foot one pretty nerdy fair bit of puffs